septembre faire des études supérieures
en bourgogne coûtera plus cher +4 27%
selon la febiac principales associations
étudiantes dans la région parmi les plus
fortes hausses l'alimentation plus de 10
% de progression alors il faut faire des
choix par exemple bang au nom par
exemple pommes de terre non ils sont
trop chers
principales dépenses étudiantes le
logement en bourgogne la progression
cette rentrée s'élève à + 2,2 pour cent
avec de grandes disparités selon les
villes + 11 % à mâcon +6 à auxerre et +
2 à dijon
cet étudiant dijonnais a choisi de
déménager pour faire baisser la note
c'est pas grand chose ça devrait être
435 euros pour le même nombre de mètres
carrés mais la différence compte la
différence contre caen compte à peu près
40 50 euros en plus chaque mois c'est
quand même notable au total sur un mois
avec l'ensemble des charges plus les
frais d'inscription et d'achat de
matériel le coût de la rentrée est
évalué à
2195 euros trop selon la febiac
l'association réclame une réforme de
l'attribution des bourses actuellement
les bourses sont faites sur les revenus
des parents et prennent très peu en
compte la situation individuelle des
étudiants avec un système de palier qui
laisse pour quelques centaines d'euros
sur le revenu fiscal des parents sans
bourse avec un échelon inférieur et nous
on veut uniformiser ça et que chaque
étudiant et sa propre bourse en fonction
de ses besoins principale crainte du
syndicat plus de précarité ouverte voilà
deux ans l'épicerie sociale du campus
pourrait ne pas désemplir cette année